christophe madrolle bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors on l'a
entendu un le président de la république
a donné hier soir une interview à la
chaîne américaine cbs
il a donc évoqué une levée progressive
des restrictions de circulation aux mets
entre les pays européens mais également
avec les états unis avec une stratégie
vaccinale qui peine à décoller là encore
on l'a vu avec notre reportage
est ce que vous y croyez à cet
allègement de restriction début mais je
vais vous dire je l'espère je l'espère
j'en ai acheté de la situation où on est
depuis un an et demi je sens le monte
d'un ras-le-bol globale dans dans notre
société on le voit tous les jours dans
vos journaux
j'espère j'espère pour nos concitoyens
j'ai envie de retrouver mon pastis sur
le vieux port à marseille janvier de
retrouver les amis j'ai envie de
retrouver une vie normale comme tous les
français qui le regardent aujourd'hui il
faut sortir et régler ce problème cette
pandémie que j'avais fait un appel fort
ya deux mois pour la vaccination
je vois que les vaccins ont du mal à
arriver dans les centres de vaccination
j'étais avant-hier au stade vélodrome où
on a monté de 5 cynodrome comme on dit
aujourd'hui
il ya deux salles y en a une qui n'a pas
pu être livré en vaccins voilà donc je
suis les mois justement à propos de ce
stock de vaccins je vous propose de
découvrir ce que disait hier renaud
muselier ce le président de la région
paca justement à propos des stocks de
vaccins regarder
quand ce vaccin sera validé par l'union
européenne qui l'aura toutes les
autorisations administratives
je serai dans les premiers à l'avoir
commandé donc le premier livre et je
suis médecin et je suis sur le terrain
ils ont pris du retard sur les commandes
anticipées des vaccins fader moderna et
astrazeneca voilà renaud muselier qui
parlait donc du spoutnik wc le vaccin
russe est ce que selon vous vous
rejoignez cette stratégie de commandes
est en avance ce vaccin justement pour
avoir suffisamment de doses dès lors que
l'europe leur a validé je rejoins
complètement la position de renaud
muselier
à un moment donné ça la politique savoir
anticiper on le dit souvent la renaud
muselier anticipe l'autorisation
probable de la mise sur le marché de ce
vaccin donc prévoir effectivement cinq
cent mille doses en amont ça permet de
pouvoir anticiper les vaccinations des
le moitié
donc oui je rejoins complètement la
proposition de renaud muselier
on l'a critiqué j'ai entendu même d'un
gouvernement certaines personnes
critiques et renaud muselier cette
position valérie pécresse a soutenu
rouleau me renaud muselier et je préfère
aujourd'hui
excusez moi qui suis un européen
convaincu on sait que les régions dans
cette protection sanitaire a été ont été
à la hauteur et donc faisons confiance
au président de région et arrêtons
systématiquement de dénigrer les prises
de position de certains des présidents
de région qui anticipe la vaccination de
leurs concitoyens alors vous êtes
également un écologiste le président
emmanuel macron et bien il s'est exprimé
sur la question du climat également hier
il a reconnu des erreurs regarder et
puis on en parle après c'est une
révolution mais pour que cette
révolution ait lieu nous devons aider
les classes moyennes et les pauvres à
faire ce changement avec nous c'est un
programme complet inclusif
j'en suis sûr maintenant je peux vous le
dire
beaucoup d'humilité j'en suis d'autant
plus sûr puisque j'ai moi-même commis
des erreurs
heijmans mistakes my stuff ce mea culpa
du chef de l'état sur la question du
climat comment est ce que vous comprenez
ce qu'ils auraient pu le faire plus tôt
que dire que dire que dire je préfère
effectivement une faute avouée que rien
du tout
ça fait plus de quatre ans que je
m'entretiens avec emmanuel macron pour
lui dire d'aller plus vite et plus fort
en matière de transition écologique et
de climat emmanuel macron l'a reconnu il
n'est pas par essence écologistes il a
été quand même
échaudé par l'expérience avec nicolas
hulot il est dû dans une logique de dire
il faut avoir une politique des petits
pas en matière de changements
climatiques
moi je peux vous dire aujourd'hui en
tant qu'écologiste qu'il faut aller vite
et fort je préfère aujourd'hui une
stratégie qui permet de pouvoir avancer
en matière d'environnement et de
protection de de la planète que de rien
du tout donc oui le président macron a
raison de dire qu'il a fait des erreurs
mais erreurs avouées n'est pas forcément
excusé et que maintenant qu'il ait fait
des erreurs qu'il s'entoure de gens qui
sache parler d'écologie et qui savent
agir sur le terrain
là encore on parlait tout à l'heure de
des régions en matière de vaccination
qu'ils fassent confiance aux élus
régionaux qui est une bonne échelle en
matière de d'action en matière
d'environnement pour pouvoir avancer et
donc et je filme infarctus et moi mais
je pense que il faut maintenant aller
vite et fort ça suffit plus de faire des
déclarations
il y a eu des avancées avec le
gouvernement mais ça doit aller plus
vite et plus fort on se souvient aussi
la convention citoyenne qui était aussi
critiqué le chef de l'état qui a
également annoncé le lancement d'un
grand débat sur la consommation de
drogue
dimanche et marine schiappa qui l
annonce une autre consultation des états
généraux sur la laïcité
cette fois quel est votre regard sur ces
méthodes cc grande consultation on en a
l'habitude maintenant avec le
gouvernement est ce que c'est efficace
vous savez ce mitterrand qui disait
quand il ya un problème on crée une
commission vous rappeler la phrase du
jour des présidents mitterrand
moi j'étais pas formats favorable à cet
aspect favorable ac thann aux
consultations
il y a des élus locaux des élus pas des
parlementaires il y a le cee qui
fonctionne il y a insuffisamment de
scientifiques autour du président mâcon
pour d'un élan avis clé encore une
commission ad-hoc pour parler parler
parler ça sert à rien voilà très clair
ça sert plus à rien l'urgence est là
l'urgence liée à la sécurité ou la
bonduelle voyons tous les jours dans vos
médias dans son imposant aux journaux
nous voyons là l'urgence climatique nous
voyons la question d'aller cité qui elle
revient comme une tarte à la crème
systématiquement tous les six mois
donc maintenant ça suffit ces
commissions à cesson faisant voter des
lois préparons des lois il y as
suffisamment d'élus qui ont travaillé
sur ces dossiers pour pouvoir avancer
j'ai toujours l'impression et c'est pas
une critique mais c'est une constatation
qu'avec ce gouvernement on revient
toujours sur une page blanche comme s'il
n'y avait jamais eu de réflexion dans le
passé on a eu quand même sur la laïcité
des grands débats en france il ya eu des
prises de position importante sur la
question du changement climatique
idem et sur la question de la sécurité
il ya eu quand même des ddd
personnalités qui ont eu des frais
réflexion sur la question des banlieues
sur les questions de la politique de la
ville sur la question de l'ordination de
la police ça sert à rien de revenir
systématiquement encore une fois faire
des consultations qui nous font perdre
des tentes agir il nous reste
malheureusement que quelques secondes
cependant amour sur cette visite à
montpellier aujourd'hui adultes du chef
de l'état justement où il va défendre sa
stratégie sécuritaire
comment est-ce que vous la jugez sa
stratégie sécuritaire du gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous en attendez
aujourd'hui en quelques mots des
solutions pour nos concitoyens
moi je vis tous les jours à marseille
devant la montée de la violence à
marseille voit la montée de la violence
en ile de france je vois dans vos
journaux ce qui s'est passé à orléans ce
l'espace à vitry je vois cette pauvre
femme qui est jeté dans dans ce métro
cette violence au quotidien on en a ras
le bol voilà donc abandonné il faut des
vraies mesures
il faut renforcer les moyens de la
police les moyens de la justice les
moyens de la politique de la ville
mettre en place des vraies mesures
ça ne suffit pas simplement de faire un
déplacement quel qu'il soit il faut
qu'il y ait des frais annonce et pas
simplement de dix mille policiers sait
quels sont les moyens donnés à la police
quels sont les moyens donnés à la
justice combien de places de prison
quel est le parcours aujourd'hui d'un
jeune que l'on arrête et qu'on retrouve
deux jours après dans la rue il faut
abandonner que la france se met à la
hauteur de ses ambitions
le respect et la liberté publique doit
primer surtout à cette période ou de
crises sanitaires qu'il faut qu'ils
aient qui compliquait pour la plupart
nos concitoyens merci beaucoup
christophe madrolle d'avoir répondu à
nos questions dans la matinale de rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes
président de l'uss et l union des
centristes et des écologistes